a pesar de ser candidata por primera vez
en las elecciones de la cámara baja de
japón moto con mis uno ve lo difícil que
es convencer a los votantes indiferentes
buenos días soy moto com/issue no estoy
obligada a presentarme primero la gente
tiene que saber qué tipo de persona soy
mucha gente va a trabajar en el metro
así que vine a la estación para
saludarlos los candidatos recorren sus
distritos electorales repitiendo
consignas a través de un altavoz como
madre soltera los antecedentes de mizuno
se consideran un obstáculo para ganar un
escaño en el parlamento de japón las
mujeres representan sólo el 10 por
ciento de los legisladores en la cámara
baja
y establecer un sistema de cuotas nos
permitiría lograr la igualdad de género
al menos en la política me temo que sin
eso las mujeres no estarán mejor
representadas
la apatía de muchos votantes es un
obstáculo para el cambio con el
parlamento dominado por hombres este
politólogo cree que los factores
culturales tienen mucho que ver
si incita a la gente a pensar que es
mejor mantener un perfil bajo conseguir
buenos trabajos en lugar de intentar
cambiar la sociedad a través de la
acción política sienten que no tiene
sentido invertir tiempo y energía en
construir una alternativa al gobierno
actual
algunas encuestas sugieren que el
partido liberal-democrático perderá
escaños pero mantendrá su mayoría aunque
si la participación es tan baja algunos
se preguntan si contará con el apoyo del
pueblo japonés